END OF THE IT.
HERTL A WRIST SHOT.
SAVE.
MEGNA WITH A SHOT, TIP,
BACKHAND, SCORE!
E LEFT OF THOMPSON, AND THAT
BACKHAND INTO UP PUCK
OFFENSIVE ZONE, TRYING TO DRIVE
TO THE NET, HE
CARRIER, AND HE SCORES!
WILL CARRIER KOLESAR, A COUPLE
OF BACKHAND PASSES, AND MEGNA,
SHOT, SCORE!
BURNS WAS DOWN LOW. REAL ROTATI
TRYING TO GET THEIR SECOND TWO-
GOAL LEAD IT AROUND THE
WALL.
DADONOV THE NET,
PROTECTS WINS THE
BATTLE.
KARLSSON SHAKES OFF DOWN GO.
FLOATED ITS WAY.
DIDN'T TOUCH ANYTHING, AS IT
MAKES IT PAST
SECOND CHANCE, SCORE!
THE SHARKS HAVE ALLOWED
DOWN THE WING!
TRIO RIGHT
THERE ON THE HANDS.
PACIORETTY.
EICHEL ON THE WALL.
OUT HIGH FOR EVIDENTLY HAD IT
LONG ENOUGH FOR THE PLAY BY
REIMER.
THEODORE FOR EICHEL.
DRIVES
LANDED THREE SHOTS ON THIS FIRS
THE HIM ON
THE BACKHAND!
>> Shane: SHEA THEODORE, A
GREAT
IN FOR SAN JOSE!